wo ist dein weg
du musst die schuhe nicht ausziehen komm
rein
der flur ist so kalt danke was kann ich
für dich tun ist nikutta ja sicher nico
er wird sicher gleichkommen vielen dank
aber ich suche nur mein portemonnaie ich
glaube nico hat es noch ich habe sind
die schwarze tasche gesteckt wir werden
es sicher finden aber erzählen mal woher
kommst du du kommst nicht aus
deutschland oder nein ich komme aus
syrien und lebe seit fast einem jahr in
deutschland bist du alleine in
deutschland nein ich bin mit meiner
eltern hier und hast du geschwister ja
ich habe zwei ältere brüder die leben
und seine großeltern meine großeltern
leben noch in syrien
das brauche ich hier oder ja danke